Oh, this is really cool. I also just
have to say it's really neat. Uh,
coming from Canada, I'm from like a
small island on the west coast of Canada.
So did we standing uh,
a Google London is kind of wild.
It's like talking about my
little book. Um, so, uh,
my name is Kate Flanders. Uh, thank
you to Nicola for inviting me here.
I have been a personal finance
blogger for the past, gosh,
like seven or eight years at this point.
Um,
my last job that I had was I was managing
editor of a financial startup for
about three years and I've done a lot
of freelance writing and the personal
finance space,
so for other financial startups,
a different banks and stuff like that.
Um,
and now I am an author, which
is pretty wild. Like I said,
cause I'm just from a little island
on the west coast of Canada. Uh,
and now I'm like,
you guys are holding a book that became
a Wall Street Journal bestseller and
everyday I'm just sort
of like what? But, uh,
it's really amazing to be here today.
So I will take you a
little bit step backwards.
Having a career in personal finance is
something that I never ever set out to do.
I can honestly say looking back on my
life and the different interests that I've
had, I never thought that
that is something I would do,
that I would be writing about how
people could be better with money. Um,
and I say that because I have
not always been good money. Uh,
so I grew up very fortunately
with a family that talked
about money all the time.
Actually we say, and it's aligned
in the, in the book, but it's true.
So my dad's a Steeler and
when your dad is a sailor,
no topic of conversation is taboo. Like
you basically talk about everything. Um,
but money was the biggest one.
So I remember things like growing up
in my dad would tell me things like how
much he made, like how much my mum made,
what they paid for their house. Um,
and actually knowing things
like how much stuff costs.
Like I remember going to the grocery
store and then actually pointing out like
how much things cost. So we knew
like, okay, for a family of five,
this is what groceries cost A.
I remember looking at their bank accounts,
like all kinds of stuff.
Like we talked about money all the time.
My Dad was also someone
who had this really,
I will say annoying when you're like 13,
14,
15 years old habit of every morning he
would read the newspaper and when he
would find an article about
anything personal finance related.
So whether it was about retirement
savings accounts, uh, real estate markets,
the economy,
just anything that was going on,
my dad would cut them out and leave
them on my bed for me to read,
like when I got home from school.
So I would like walk into the house,
walk into my room and see these and
immediately roll my eyes and Groan and be
like, I have no interest in reading this
right now. Uh, and unfortunately didn't.
I will say that even though my dad
talked to me about money all the time,
I still made a lot of mistakes.
And I think that's sort of just
something that happens in life.
We don't do everything just the way that
our parents have hoped that we would.
So I will say right now, I'm
32 years old. When I was 25,
I was maxed out with
close to $30,000 of debt.
And that was basically just consumer
debt. So it wasn't even, um,
student loans.
Like I didn't even have a great excuse
for why I was in that amount of debt.
And if I were to switch that into pounds,
I mean, you guys might know this stuff.
I'd say it's probably like 16,
17,000 pounds of like just consumer debt.
And when I say maxed out,
I was truly maxed out at $100 left in my
bank account and $100 left on one of my
credit cards. And I somehow had to
make that last me for six weeks.
So I had no choice at that point.
But to start taking my finances seriously
and to start paying off my debt. Um,
and so I started this little blog that
I wrote anonymously for a long time.
Uh, that I thought was just going to be
this little place on the Internet where I
could document my debt repayment journey.
No one was supposed to read it.
Like I never intended to ever have an
audience or readership or anything like
that. All I wanted to do, and
it was as boring as this is,
I would write these weekly spending
reports so we could have spinning reports
literally looked like, just like Monday
I spent $2 and 91 cents at Starbucks.
Tuesday I spent $2 and
91 cents it Starbucks,
maybe I spent some money on groceries
or something else Wednesday,
Thursday cause I like it.
That's all it was.
I would post these every Sunday
was nothing exciting about them.
But then people started reading them
and commenting and I was like, why?
What's going on here?
And then I found this whole world
of personal finance bloggers,
a lot of people doing the same thing.
So this was 2011,
2012 a couple of years after
kind of financial crash.
So I think everyone is sort of finally
coming to this place of like, okay,
it's time to really start getting serious
with what we're doing with our money.
What I will say is about being maxed
out at that point is that it weighed so
heavily on me that I became extremely
aggressive about my debt repayment
approach.
So I can't say that I had like the best
techniques for the way that I paid off
my debt. I also look back at it
and think that it was extremely,
um, not just aggressive. Like
I was really hard on myself.
So I think I used to say to myself
when I was in debt was like,
you're a bad person.
You've screwed up all your chances
of having a strong financial future.
Kind of like,
I deserve to be punished and not have
any sort of fun money or free money
because I had just gotten myself into
this horrible situation and so I had just
deserved whatever it
took to get out of it.
And I paid off my debt in two years.
And that sounds great on paper,
but the problem then was that
throughout those two years,
I hadn't taken the time to learn why
I had actually gotten into debt in the
first place. So I didn't
understand what my habits were.
I didn't know actually what I had been
overspending on all those years before.
Like I kinda had this record of the past
two years when I was paying off my debt,
but I didn't really know anything about
myself as a consumer because just for
those two years I was just like
anti consumption, anti everything,
which we can talk about that. Like I'm
more in the mindful zone of that now. Uh,
but I, I didn't know anything
about myself. So on top
of being super aggressive,
being hard on myself and
not learning anything,
it's not that surprising to
me that once I was debt free,
I actually just went back to
spending basically all of my money.
So there were months when I was paying
off my debt where I would put up to 55%
of my income towards debt repayment.
And that was great. But again,
a little bit too aggressive,
like not quite, uh,
something that could be sustainable.
Cause again, I had no fun money.
I didn't allow myself to do
anything just for pure pleasure,
like the simplest things that you enjoy
it. I didn't let myself do any of it.
So there were months back then,
55% of my income going towards debt and
then the first year that I was debt free
and I should have been set up right,
like to have this much more
successful financial future,
I should have been able to
achieve all kinds of goals.
And instead I was saving maybe 5% of
my income and I would write these blog
posts then where I would say
at the beginning of every
month that I wanted to be
saving 20% of my income. And then at
the end of every month I would be like,
oh hey guys.
Remember when I said that thing
I actually saved like 3% or 5%?
I think like the most was
about 12, uh, an entire year.
And it's not that I was saving nothing
but it's that writing that down every
single month did not feel good.
Like it didn't feel good to share it
and have to tell people that had not
achieved my goal but also just didn't
feel good for me cause I knew that I could
do better and that I really wanted to.
So I will tell you about this challenge
that I decided to sort of set out for
myself. But everyone upfront
like a question is always like,
oh why did you start doing it? Like what
was the goal? And I'm like, to be honest,
like I think we,
we wish it was sort of like
a more dramatic story or
we wish that there was some
like huge I a rock bottom moment or
something like that. But I think for me,
something I've learned
about myself is that I'm,
I usually create change in my life
after I've been thinking about it for a
really long time and eventually get
to a place where I'm just really
uncomfortable and have to make
a change. So for me, all it was,
was that once a month
for 12 months in a row,
I would think like I
can do better than this.
I don't know exactly
what that looks like yet,
but like I'm not happy with what I
just did. I know I can do better.
So what does that look like?
And then after a year of being debt free,
not that surprisingly how to another
money conversation with my family.
My sister at the time was 20 years old
and I was 29 and we're sitting at my
parents' house,
we're all just kind of hanging out and
my sister starts telling us about how she
had just bought some camera or
something for like $500 I keep in mind,
she's like a full time university student.
She has working part time but she
doesn't have a ton of extra money.
So we're all just kind of
picking at her and being like,
oh like you should save more
of your money. Like don't
spend it all. And she goes,
yeah, but I saved 20% of my income so
I can do whatever I want with the rest.
And so first of all I'm like, wait, what?
How has my sister figured
this out before me?
How she's even 20% on her part
salary and I can't even do that.
Making a decent income at
a financial startup. Okay.
But then the words that came out of
my mouth were just automatic. I don't,
I didn't even think of them before I
said them. I just said to her, yeah,
but you live at home.
Like do you really need 80% of your
income or could you live on less?
And then like it was one of the things
where I have no idea what anybody else
said for like the next five minutes.
And in my head I'm like, Whoa,
like where did that question come from?
Why have I never asked myself that?
Like do I need 90 or 95% of my income
or could I be living on less than that?
And so the wheels just
started turning from there.
And within like a couple of weeks,
I just sort of wrote down these rules for
something that I called a shopping ban.
When I think about the shopping ban now,
I sort of wish I had called it something
different because it sounds incredibly
restrictive upfront. It's like no
shopping, you can't buy anything.
That's not what the goal is. And that's
not even what that year looked like.
I just sort of had this idea that I
didn't want to buy anything unless I
absolutely needed it. And also knowing
like I had never shopped like that before.
I'd never spent money like that before.
Like waited until I
actually needed something.
I used to be someone who made a
lot of preemptive purchases, right?
Like you just buy things because
you think I'll need it one day.
It will help me in that scenario.
But I never waited until I just needed
the thing and then you buy the thing.
So I just wrote these
rules down and I will say,
so there were three different lists.
The first list was the things I
was allowed to buy. So basic stuff,
I could,
you could call it even like consumables.
So I was obviously allowed to buy
groceries. I can put gas in my car.
Uh,
buy toiletries when you run out of them.
Like I'm always like if you run
out of deodorant and toothpaste,
everyone in your life wants
you to buy more of that stuff,
so please buy more of it. So anything
that you are using often and run out of,
buy it, buy more of the stuff that you
need, that's fine when you run out of it.
The things I could not buy a,
that list was a lot longer. Um,
so I couldn't buy clothes, uh,
shoes, books, magazines, um,
electronics, things for around
the house. And then I added, um,
take up coffee to that list of things
I couldn't buy. And I will say,
I'm not a personal finance writer who's
like, you're not allowed your $5 latte.
Like, I just had a $5 Latte,
we'll a $5 Canadian law day.
So I'm not one of those people who says
that I was just at the point with my
finances where I was no longer comfortable
with how much I was spending on it
and I was doing it strictly out of habit.
Like it wasn't because I genuinely wanted
the coffee even it's just like this
thing that I did all the time. And so I
was just still doing it. So I was like,
no more ticket coffee either.
I also created this other short list
because I decided to do this for an entire
year.
So I started trying to look ahead a
little bit and just think of a few things
that I might need in that
upcoming year. Um, so one was, uh,
I had five weddings to go to and I'm
not really someone who dresses up in
general. So I was like, I
need an outfit, one outfit,
dress shoes or whatever and that
will be for all of the weddings. Uh,
I knew that I had no kind of winter
boots and actually these are the ones I
bought. So I bought these in 2014 and just
still wear them now, which is great. Um,
and there was something else I really
wanted, it was if I could save the money,
I really wanted to buy a new bed that
year because my bed was 13 years old.
And I think because it
was a bigger ticket item,
I could never seem to save and
actually afford to replace it.
So interesting to look back
at the psychology of that.
Like in all my years previous, I was
so quick to spend $20 here, $30 there,
et Cetera, et Cetera, et Cetera,
how quickly that stuff adds up.
And I could have just had $1,000
to buy a bed back then. But anyway,
so I was like, if I can save the money,
I would really like to buy a bed.
That just was important to me.
So I started this challenge
on my 29th birthday,
so it was July of 2014.
Um, right up front.
I also decided to start sort of a
secondary challenge, which again, like I,
I still think I, or wish I had a
better reason for why I started it,
but I just sorta got on
that kick of decluttering.
I definitely recognize the fact that I'd
been spending a bunch of money on stuff
that I probably didn't really need,
wasn't even using.
I could look around my home and see that
I had more than enough stuff and there
was so much that I wasn't wearing any
more. It wasn't reading it, touching it,
whatever.
Like I just wasn't using this stuff.
So at the same time that I
decided to stop shopping,
I also decided I was going to declutter,
which sounds really counterintuitive,
but it ended up being,
uh,
like the very weird and great challenge
to do together because it all taught me
about becoming a more mindful
consumer in general. Uh,
so I set out to do that
when I started decluttering.
I will say like that was the
very first thing I sort of did.
Like the starting the shopping ban
felt easy in the first few weeks. Um,
but when I, I started decluttering
at the exact same time,
what was so interesting about
that was that I took inventory,
which sounds so boring,
but I took inventory of not only the
amount of stuff that I got rid of,
but also the things I was keeping.
Now,
the reason that was ended
up being so important,
like I was strictly doing
it for a data point.
Like I'm so nerdy that throughout this
entire process I was literally tracking
percentages of how much stuff I got rid
of, how much stuff I kept. And it was,
it was just purely for me. Like it,
it didn't matter for anyone else.
I was just super curious how the
numbers were going to add up. Uh,
and so the first couple of months,
like I ended up decluttering 43% of my
belongings in like just maybe a month and
a half, two months. And it
was really easy at first.
But that list of inventory
of the things that I kept,
the reason it ended up being so important
was because it helped me stop or it's
helped stop me from making
a lot of impulse purchases.
So throughout the shopping ban,
there were numerous times where
I did think about buying things,
but then I was able to just sorta
late sort of mentally check and go,
you know what?
When I started this,
I actually still owned over 50
books that I haven't even read yet.
I do not need to buy more books. Uh, and
the same thing just for like toiletries,
kind of the things you have the most of.
So when people ask me now like, well,
what should I do if I was going
to start a shopping ban? I'm like,
don't even start one to be honest.
Like start by taking inventory
of the stuff you own,
because I think that alone will
help people to start making more,
some of the impulse purchases there
they're more inclined to make.
So I decluttered took inventory.
Um,
and then I noticed kind of month two,
that is where the first time things
really started to feel like they were a
little bit trickier. And
when I say this, okay,
journalists keep asking me like what
the hardest part was. And I'm like,
to be honest, like the hardest part was
really changing habits and the things,
so the things you do all the time.
So one of the hardest things for
me was to give up takeout coffee.
And then journalists laugh at that
sometimes like, oh, how silly.
Like you're just like, what a frivolous
thing. And I'm like, no, you don't get it.
Like it's not about the takeout coffee,
it's that that is something I was doing
habitually, almost every single day,
which means that every single day I'm
then in that moment where I'm like, oh,
I want to do this thing. Oh, but I can't.
And so you have to stop and start figuring
out like what your triggers were and
why you were thinking of doing that. Uh,
and, and just and change your reaction.
Like I had never thought of changing my
reaction before. I always just like one,
I thought of getting to a good coffee,
I just immediately got it.
So it was the first time that I really
had to start thinking about why I was
even considering getting takeout coffee
and then changing my reaction to that.
Uh, Gosh. What was like
the hardest part's yeah,
take up coffee books where the next
biggest one, and again it's a habit,
like I used to have this really bad
habit and it's so easy with stuff like
Amazon, like you just hear of
something online and you are,
you can hear it from anywhere and you
immediately click over and you go to buy
the thing and then back then it was like,
you need $25 to get the free shipping.
You just like add something
else. It sounds kind of
okay, get your free shipping,
bing, Bang, boom. I do that like
once a week or once every two weeks.
I did not read that many books like I
really wish that I did, but I never did.
It's very rare that I read that many
books, but I did it all the time,
which meant that at least once or twice
a week I was kind of sitting there being
like, well that book sounds
good. What do I do now?
And so the in the beginning like noticing
that those were the two toughest ones
for me that would look different for
everyone because everyone's spending is so
personal.
And that's why again,
like people ask me what shopping bans
are doing something similar all the time.
I don't think yours is going
to look different than mine.
And what's hard for you is going to look
different than what looked hard for me
because everyone's are different.
Like the things that we have habits for.
Some of them are kinda similar but
often not like everyone's values are so
different.
So those were the toughest parts.
The changing the habit part is what then
became the most important thing for me
was like with the tater coffee. Pretty
easy. Honestly, when you guys are lucky,
like at work it would just be here
for you. For me it was like, okay,
well instead of going up
to get takeout coffee,
I just have to kind of
leave all the stuff for,
take it like making coffee on the counter
at all times. Like if it's just there,
then you do it and then that becomes
a habit and like an enjoyable habit.
I started enjoying coffee every morning
and almost noticing it became this like
really nice routine because I was working
remotely for the startup that I was at
and I would just enjoy my kind of slow
mornings getting up, making the coffee,
kind of listening to a
podcast or something,
just relaxing a little bit
and then starting the day
it was so much easier than
just an actually isn't that even were to
think of it like I was working remotely
and somehow it used to seem easier to
get dressed and go downstairs to get
coffee rather than just to make
coffee. But it was just a habit. Uh,
so changing that habit was easy.
The are easy over time.
The books one was tough. Like I
thought about buying books for a long,
long time.
Uh,
I will say that I became very good friends
with my library and I actually had to
get a new credit card that year because
mine like had been compromised and so
they have to send you a new number
and all of that. Still to this day,
it's been almost four years. I do not
have that credit card number memorized.
I used to know all of them off by heart
because it was just so easy to do online
shopping.
I still don't know what that one is,
but I memorized my library card number
within probably three weeks of having it
because I used it all the time.
Uh,
and then another question I get, so
aside from like my personal habits is a,
how did friends deal with it?
That's probably the most common question
I get at any kind of event that I do
now. Like what had friends
do? What had family do?
I feel super fortunate that
my friends and family, uh,
were mostly pretty supportive family.
Definitely.
I think also because over the years the
thing that they had watched me do was
sort of take on these big challenges.
And just do them.
Like other things I'd written on the blog
was not only paying off my debt in two
years,
um,
but I also quit drinking in those two
years and I'm very open and honest about
that in the book. So if you do read it,
you will find a lot of stories about that.
Um, and I also decided to sort of take
control of my health. I lost 30 pounds.
I started training for
my first half marathon.
Like I was just doing these
big challenges. So family
was just like, oh yeah,
like you'll do this thing.
No problem.
What was more interesting with friends
is that at first I will say our struggle
was more just that friends didn't
really seem to get the point.
So I would find out all my friends had
gone out for dinner or something like
that. I'm like, wait, where was my invite?
And then they'd be all confused and be
like, well, I thought I wasn't a lot.
You weren't going to dinner. I'm like, no,
I can go to dinner and beg me to dinner.
Like I'm allowed to do that if I want
to do that. So they're like, oh, okay.
So friends seemed confused all the time.
What was more interesting was when
I would find myself listening to
conversations with friends,
where they were talking about how much
stuff they had bought or like the deals
they had got or where they'd
bought something from.
And I don't think I had ever realized
how socially normal it is to talk about
shopping.
Like I was really naive when I started.
I just kinda thought no one would
care and it wouldn't be a big deal.
And then this is something I also noticed,
obviously when I quit drinking,
like drinking is very culturally normal.
And so you're in a lot of conversations
where now you're like, okay,
I'm not part of this conversation anymore.
Like I can't,
I can't add anything to it.
I can't participate in any way.
And we shopping, I just didn't
think that was going to be a thing,
but it came up all the time.
And it can be as simple as like,
where did you get your shoes?
Where did you get your bag? Oh,
what book are you reading right now?
Where did you get it from?
Who did you hear about?
Like just anything.
People talk about the stuff
that they buy all the time.
And so it's not that friends cared.
It was really that it was one of those
moments. And I, I think about this a lot,
like when,
especially when you're sober,
you often find yourself in situations
where you feel like the only sober person
in the room because
you genuinely are like,
it's the only one who isn't participating.
Uh,
and with these conversations that ended
up being the same. Uh, so I will say,
I mean the first six months or
so of the shopping ban, we're,
we're just tough. And in terms of
like figuring out what my habits,
where I had to change them,
uh,
and then also starting to question a
little bit more what my value is actually
were and the things I actually
did want to be spending money on,
but it got a little, little bit
tougher about halfway through. Um,
some of the book,
I talk about it a lot,
but my parents ended up announcing that
they were getting divorced that year and
I think it was the first time that
I really recognized that I was more,
I'll just say like an emotional consumer.
So I think what I realized that year was
that in the past what I would've done
was probably drank my way through that.
Um,
I'm also pretty honest about like
when I was younger like binge eating,
things like that and because I didn't
have those and now I also didn't have
spending as an option a,
I had to do the tougher part,
which is you just have to feel the hard
feelings and that's not great advice.
Sort of like people are always
like, okay, if you couldn't do that,
like what did you do? And
I'm like, I cried a lot that
year. Like it was really, no,
not that exciting. It wasn't a great
year all around or for all parts of it.
But it was a really hard year and I had
to learn how to feel feelings for the
first time and just like get through it.
So what ended up getting easier after
that was finally coming to a place where I
had a goal, like I didn't have a
goal really when I got started,
I sort of wrote these few things down.
I'm like,
I want to spend less
and I want to save more.
And it was definitely just this kind
of financial journey that I was on.
But then I just thought I'd or,
and the other part of that was that I
said I wanted to also become more mindful
consumer,
which I truly was just kind of making up.
Like I didn't even know what
that really meant when I'm like,
that sounds like a good thing. Like
if I could be a more mindful consumer,
that sounds great,
but I didn't really have a financial goal.
So at halfway through like I was doing
pretty good. I was saving typically,
but like 20% of my income every month.
And I was spending a bit on
travel for the first time,
which felt great because travel was
something I'd always wanted to do,
but I'd never seem to have the money
to do it because I was sorta just
mindlessly spending money on whatever
else. Um, so he's spending it on travel,
living on much less than I had been
before. Uh, but then I decided,
or sort of in looking at my
finances, realize that not
only was I living on less,
but I was also doing a bit more freelance.
Um,
to the point that I realized
I was actually earning
the amount of money that I
was living on at that time.
So it started to become an option to me
that I could maybe quit and either work
for myself or just figure something out.
And that is a position I had never been
in and never even imagined being in
before. Like, I'd never thought to
myself that I would work for myself.
Like I grew up with parents who worked
in the public service and so I just
entrepreneurship or whatever,
like it just wasn't something I ever
aspired to or thought would be part of my
future.
But once I realized that my spending was
exactly how much I was already earning
just on the side, I'm like, okay,
like there's a little bit more
motivation here to keep going.
And I sort of kicked it into high gear at
that point. Um, in the last six months,
you know, I, I made this decision
to quit my job and I ended up, uh,
on those months, I don't know,
like there were months in there,
I probably stayed up to 45% of my income
and by the end of it had enough money
that I felt completely
comfortable quitting and knew
that even if I could only
do it for like six or eight months,
I had tons of money.
Like I had lined up a ton of work and
I had tons of money in the bank. Um,
and that I could at least make it work
for probably six months to a year.
And that it just would
have been worth trying.
And I was someone who never
took chances on myself before.
Like when I really look back at
the kind of consumer that I was,
I used to buy things for all the wrong
reasons and I had an even when as a
drinker too,
like I wrapped so much of myself worth
up in the wrong things and in trying to
be someone that I actually wasn't.
And in that year I ended up
decluttering 70% of my belongings. Um,
as part of that,
I remember the toughest part right towards
the end of decluttering was realizing
that everything left over
was stuff I actually used.
But there were these few items that I
had held onto that was sort of for this
more like aspirational version of myself.
So I used to buy books that
I would think like I dunno,
like a smarter or just more interesting
version of myself might read or I buy
clothes that like a more professional
or put together version of myself might
wear um, creative projects where a
big one, I had so many different,
like everything from a DSLR camera to
scrap booking stuff to painting stuff.
Like I had all these different materials
for creative projects that I thought I
might do one day,
but I never did any of them because the
real me wasn't actually interested in
any of it.
And so I remember in letting go of all
of that and sort of letting go that
through that entire year of just
all the stuff that I didn't need,
I realize the things that I actually do
value and who I really am as a person.
And it became a lot easier to start
making spending decisions once I actually
knew who I was already. So I don't want
to like cut it short there, but I'm like,
there's more I could
say, but I, I don't know.
I've seen like a few phases where I'm
like, are there any questions yet?
Oh, no. Uh, okay. Well,
what I'll say is that when I finished
the year, uh, I had quit my job.
I had lived on an average
of 51% of my income.
I saved 31% of it and I spent 18% on
travel, which was a lot of money. Um,
but I'd never been able to do that before.
And so even if we had cut that out though,
like if I hadn't spent anything on travel,
I would've saved 49% of my income.
And a lot of that just came back to
making more mindful decisions every day,
every week. Not that I was buying
nothing. I also want to say I,
I don't believe that buying stuff
is bad or spending money is bad.
I buy things now and I spend money.
I'm obviously,
I'm on a six week vacation right now and
I've bought books since I've been here
and, and a few other things. Like I
don't think it's about that. It really,
for me it was about getting to a place
where I could figure out like who I was
and it make spending decisions so much
easier because now I know when I make a
purchase it's for something I actually
need or I really want it in that moment.
Like it feels really amazing to buy a
book because you genuinely really want to
read it. And like that day you sit down
and read it in three or four hours,
I feels really good. And that is
something I can't say about past me.
I never knew how to do that, but uh, yeah,
I'll leave it there for now.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Thank you.
So the only part you haven't mentioned
yet is when you decided to write the book
and how you went from kind of this
experiment to becoming an author.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So the question, uh,
just being about when I
decided to write the book, um,
I don't know that that was a decision.
It was this really amazing twist of
events that happened after I finished the
year. So, um,
I earlier that year I had done an
interview with someone at Forbes and the
interview was about someone else.
She was like,
I know cause I knew kind of everyone
in the personal finance space and she's
like, I know that you have a good
relationship with this person.
I'm doing a profile on them and I'd really
love a couple of quotes of just like
what they mean to the community.
So we did this great interview,
she got the quotes and at
the end of it she goes,
now when you're done doing like
the finger doing like let me know,
we can write a profile about it.
So I reached out to her about a month
before because I knew like the last couple
months especially, I was like,
I've got this in the bag.
Like this shopping ban thing is
just like a way of life. Like,
I'm saving as much money as I can
so I can quit my job. This is easy.
So I emailed her to say like, Hey, I'm,
I'm almost done. I'll be done soon.
Let's do the interview.
And the date came out,
which was actually the last day of
the shopping. Bam. Uh, it came out,
she emailed me the link that
morning and goes, just Fyi,
these things have a tendency
to go viral and I'm like, what?
And within two weeks I had been contacted
by six different literary agents. So I,
I never made that decision.
Like that was sort of something that came
after and it's been really interesting
because I, I think, um, as a
writer, like as a creative,
you sort of struggle with like
I didn't set out to do it,
but at the same time I was writing about
something that people are obviously
thinking about. And so I mean, publishers,
literary agents just like saw that and
it just became an option. It sort of,
one of the things too,
like it was like quitting my job
was never the goal either. Right.
And it just became an option.
It was the first time where I was really
in a position where I could take an
opportunity and kind of move forward
with it. So it just became an option.
Right.
You gave that buying the book.
It is.
Although I will say about that too is
like I don't tell anyone to just like go
out and buy the book and always
like I talk about this now,
like I buy books when I
know I'm going to read it.
So if it feels like something
you want to read now,
then buy it or ask your
library if they have it.
I don't know how the library
system works over here,
but like in North America you can just
go and ask your library to get the book.
And that also helps authors, like
authors, not maybe in over here,
but in North America,
author is actually like a small amount,
like get paid out every single time your
book is checked out. So just an Fyi,
like it's just as not maybe just as
good, but it's all helps. It all helps.
And so I'm, yeah, I just
always think about that. Like,
I would never go out and tell
anyone to buy, buy any book.
But yeah, no, the irony is
real and it is not lost on me.
Come up.
What would you say are some of
the treats that you've kind of,
so you mentioned travel,
but just aside from that,
what would you say that you're doing
now that you haven't done before that is
maybe a splurge or an expense that you
wouldn't have considered? Like a, yeah,
like a tree.
Um,
well it's funny like the word treat,
and I talk about this a
little bit in the book,
the word like treat or treat yourself.
Things like Yolo,
like all just sorta different
phrases that are out there.
The reason I don't like them just
sort of in general, like not,
not even just that we
say them to each other.
Although part of that that I don't like
is that like I think everyone truly
wants to be saving more money and yet
we've created these little phrases where
we're all encouraging each other
to spend more. It's really weird.
So I don't like that word because for
me it makes it still feel like it's
something I shouldn't be
having, sort of. So for me,
I actually believe like I don't really
have thoughts on like needs versus wants.
Like if you really want something, it's
just a need. If it fits in your budget,
it's a need. So I would
say now as a consumer, um,
I mean I pretty much never buy clothes.
There's all these things that like I just
realized I don't care about. But I do,
I mean I buy books,
I don't buy more than I read,
but it feels really amazing now too.
Um,
I would say I buy more
books in bookstores.
Like I don't buy anything
online really anymore.
And that for me has
come from this place of,
it's so much different to walk into a
bookstore, really read a few pages of it,
like get an actual feel for what the
book is like and then making the decision
to buy it rather than just like hearing
about it immediately getting it online.
Um, so I probably spend more on books
because I do it that way. But I also,
it's like something that's super
weird or like people keep calling me a
minimalist.
I'm like,
I don't even know if I would call myself
one because I do like tangible stuff.
Like I like real books.
I don't really like Ebooks,
so probably just bookstore
just differently.
It's just a lot different buying
them now than it used to be.
Yeah.
One of the things, uh, uh,
people say it's never with credit cards
and online you mentioned that you don't
actually track the money you're spending.
It's very easy because you don't
actually physically experience that in.
Do you use any tricks like playing more
with cash or something like this or any
kind of similar things you mentioned
going to the actual bookstores?
Yeah. And anything else? Um,
it's funny that tea, I like,
I love that question because my answer
is still is not great in the sense of,
I think it's going to be
personal for everyone.
So I remember trying a cash budget,
uh,
years ago actually when I was trying to
pay off my debt and it just did not work
for me,
or at least like the way I was doing it.
I think because I had tried
to really restrict myself.
Like this is the amount of
money I'm allowed for two weeks.
But then like things genuinely do
come up in that time. You're like,
even if it's only $20, you're like
actually really need that money.
Like what am I supposed to do now?
Um, so cash doesn't quite work for me.
I would say now, like I basically pay for
everything with credit, but it's comes,
it's, I mean that's been a cycle. Like
when I paid on was paying off my debt.
I never used my credit for
about a year after that.
I didn't really love using it.
And then now I'm just at a place that
I'm really comfortable with my spending
because I,
I know I won't overspend.
Like I trust myself and
look at my spending weekly
and so I just know that I'm
doing okay. But I think it really, um,
it's really personal for everyone.
The one thing that I have done for a long
time and still do that to this day is
I actually put pen to paper
and write things down.
So in a journal I will literally write
down how much I spend everyday on,
on what, um, and I don't do
that quite as much anymore,
but I did it for years because for
me there's something so different.
It was the same way as like
publishing on the blog.
Like knowing that I had to write down
the exact amounts and put it out there,
I naturally just started to spend less
because you'd see like, Oh, you know what,
it actually doesn't feel great to be
spending money on Starbucks like every
single day. It's maybe I'm going to cut
it down just a little bit. Um, so I would,
I don't know, like I'm super old school,
I love technology for so many things,
but there's something about spending
like writing it down by hand.
It just helped me become more
mindful of it over the years.
Okay.
Hi.
Um, so I guess it's been quite a bit of
trial and error through the process. Um,
my question is more about like,
is there anything over this
amount of time or like are there,
is there one thing that you would have
done differently or like anything that
you particularly regret around
decisions that you made?
Good question. Um, I don't know
about doing it differently.
I guess I actually forgot about one story
and this is that it was I guess four,
four and a bit months into the first
year of the shopping ban. Cause I will,
I actually didn't even say this,
but when the first year was over,
I ended up doing it for a second year. Um,
and again just for sort of data points,
which is super boring,
but I was super about things like
how much stuff do I actually use?
Like how many things of toothpaste do I
actually use in a year or deodorant or
lotion or cosmetics, like
things like that. Um,
so I will say it was a
regret in the first year.
I sort of wished I had
kept track of all of that.
And not because it's like
earth shattering information,
like it doesn't even matter
to anyone else except for me.
But having that information now,
like tracking that for a year,
it really helped me figure out,
it's sort of like an semi
average female consumer.
Like how much stuff am I actually using?
Which then it just keeps preventing me
from making impulse purchases. Right?
Like I'm like,
I know that I don't need to go stock up
on stuff because it takes a long time to
actually use things up. So
that was sort of a, a regret.
But one thing that did happen was four,
four and a half months into
it on black Friday came up.
And one of the things that I had done
when I started the shopping ban was I
unsubscribed from basically everything.
And I also unfollowed like all
retailers on social media. Um,
so I thought I was doing great.
Like I wasn't really getting
those emails anymore.
I wasn't being told about all
the different things I could buy.
So I thought it was doing good.
And then somehow in black Friday I got
an email from my favorite bookstore and I
actually talked myself
in to buying something.
So I talked myself into and like it
was really this exercise after that,
like, cause it happens so quickly and
like people call the impulse purchases.
And in that moment I was like,
I've actually done this a lot before
and it feels a lot more like a blackout
purchase where like it's so quick
and then all of a sudden you have a
confirmation email that's like, here's
this thing you did. You're like, wait,
I did what?
Like how much did I just spend?
So on black Friday that happened.
So all of a sudden I see that I have
an ereader, like a confirmation.
I have bought a new ereader, I immediately
canceled the order and then go,
what just happened?
And I realized there are so many stories
we tell ourselves to justify something.
And it's not that the ereader would
have been bad per say. Mine was broken.
So these are like the stories
I was telling myself. Mine
was broken. It did work.
But you had to, um, you know,
like the reset pin or like little
hole you have to stick a pin in.
I had to do that every time
I wanted to turn it on.
So I sort of had to have a
pin available at all times.
So it's sort of would have helped me but
I didn't need it and I didn't actually
need it.
So I'm telling myself all this stuff
and like you haven't bought yourself
anything in so long and you've never
seen it this low before in price and,
and all this stuff. It happens so quickly
and then you just make the purchase.
And so I think it wasn't a regret because
actually something I realized that
year was that passed me anytime I would
have sort of like screwed up a challenge
or like gone off track,
old me would have been really hard on
myself and sort of just shamed myself and
made myself feel really,
really bad for it.
And that was the first time I was
like a have to take this as a learning
experience instead,
figure out what just happened.
So that going forward I can just start
changing my behavior or becoming more
cognizant,
like in that specific example of like
what are the stories I tell myself before
thinking about making a purchase?
Hi. Uh, this is probably quite a
difficult question, but I wondered,
having gone through everything you've gone
through and thinking about everything,
uh,
in the way that you have,
what are your thoughts on how far your
behavior in the past was kind of innate
human behavior?
Or how much was it based on the context
we all find ourselves in now where
there's so much stuff available?
No,
it's a really good question.
So it's sorta two parts or
just like part of it is,
I don't know because I don't know what
my old spending was like when I got into
debt, especially I never tracked
spending in my life. Right.
I just kept seeing that my balance
was growing and I stopped. I truly,
it was so bad.
I stopped looking at my credit cards.
I just saw that the balance was growing
and as long as I could make the minimum
payment, I felt like I was going
to be okay. And so I don't know,
honestly what old me
really spent money on. Um,
I'm guessing there was probably not only
social like influence from things like
social media,
but just generally social influence.
Like when your friends are doing
something, you just do it too. Um,
I also know parts of my debt came from
partying too much or just in the sense of
like, I never wanted to say no. So
anytime's a friends asked me to hang out.
I would just say yes even if it
meant I was putting it on credit. Um,
so I dunno, like I'm sure there's
a mix of kind of both there.
But I do know at the end of the day when
I look at some of the things that I was
buying and some of the stuff I was
spending money on and especially with
partying,
like so much of my self worth was wrapped
up in the fact that I was a really
good partier and people
loved partying with me.
And I truly like as
soon as I quit drinking,
I almost had like an identity crisis
of just like I don't even know what I'm
good at or why people would want to be
friends with me or want to hang out with
me. Um, because that was my life.
My life was so revolved around
partying that I just didn't get it.
So not only in trying to figure that
out and then decluttering and looking at
some of my stuff,
I'm like,
there's so much stuff I used
to do for the wrong reason.
Like I just didn't understand
who I was as a person.
And in starting to just
like kind of let stuff go.
That was the first time I really
started to figure it out and I'm like,
the answers were so simple. I'm
like, I'm a writer, I'm a reader.
So like I like books, like a
writer. I'm a reader, I hike a lot.
I'm a sister, I'm a friend,
I'm a daughter, like who I am.
They're actually all pretty simple things.
And so once I sort of figured that's about
it, it just made spending easier now,
but old me, I dunno, I'd say a big macs.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Um, like how regimen did you gain? Like
when you first started, like did you,
were you like watching how much we'll
see you are using in the shower and that
Sorta
oh, is it just spending just Benning? Just
finish it? Yeah. Yeah. No, just Benning.
Yeah.
No,
that's a good question though because
that's sort of a topic in general that's
pretty hot right now too,
of like extreme for gallery and the
things that people will do to sort of cut
back.
Um,
that for me has never quite aligned
like who I am or whatever about,
because like I said,
I still went to restaurants and I
bought something if I needed it.
Like there were a few things that year
and I think women can probably relate to
this.
Like I only owned one pair of jeans and
they ripped in the inner thigh and like
that only lasts for so long.
Like you can only fix that so many times
for you have to replace that. That uh,
so, so no, it wasn't about
like spending no money.
It was really for the first time like
having to ask myself like why I'm thinking
of buying something. I almost
think to like make a visual of it.
Like it was kind of putting a barrier
between me and every single purchase where
you almost were like hitting the pause
button and like asking yourself a few
questions before you're doing it.
So instead of just automatically
making the purchase, getting the thing,
it was kind of like hitting
pause and just going, Huh,
like do I really need this thing?
What's going on in my head right now?
How am I feeling?
What's going on in my life?
What influencers are around me right
now? Like what's going on? Um, but yeah.
Yeah.
Thank you very much,
Kate. Thank you. Clothes.
[inaudible].